hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast Labrador enter a
multi-material 3d bioprinting platform
for building living tissues on-demand
presented by dr. samuel large words
chief scientific officer and co-founder
of aspect bio systems
I am Marjorie Torres of laberd's and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labrys laborat to the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located in the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Samuel watts work I will now turn the
presentation over to him well thank you
very much hello everyone my name is Sam
Rogers I'm co-founder and chief
scientific officer of aspect bio systems
and thank you for the opportunity to
tell you about our lab on a printer bio
printing technology today before I
discuss the details of our unique
platform technology
talk about why we want to bio-print in
the first place and how we think it will
improve the way we treat disease and
develop therapeutics although we've come
a long way since the very first
successful organ transplant in 1952 with
many lives saved we're faced with a
widening gap between donor organs supply
and demand currently approximately 122
thousand people are on the organ donor
waiting list in the USA and then
estimated 22 people die every day
waiting for a donor organ with several
years away and further scientific and
technological advancement will be needed
but bio printing technology holds the
potential to enable the production of
human tissues for implantation allowing
us to close the gap between organs
supply and demand before bio printing
technology is used to tackle the bold
challenge of donor organ shortage there
are near-term applications of bio
printing technology that could
significantly impact the way we treat
disease and develop drugs if we look at
the current drug development process we
see that the pharmaceutical industry
relies heavily on the use of simple
two-dimensional cell cultures and animal
models to investigate novel therapeutics
during the preclinical phase of testing
candidate molecules that show promise
advanced into clinical trials where
they're tested in humans and this is
where the problems really start over 90%
of drugs end up failing in clinical
trials with each late stage failure
costing about 200 million dollars that
means of the estimated three to four
billion dollars it takes to develop one
successful drug about 1.8 billion goes
towards drugs that never make it to the
market and importantly never end up
saving or improving lives
with simple two-dimensional cell
cultures we often cannot capture the
relevant complexity of the invivo micro
environment and animal models often
misrepresent the human response for many
disease indications with 3d bio printed
tissues we can better mimic the signals
from the micro environment observed in
native tissues and study cell to cell
and cell extracellular matrix
interactions in a human relevant system
and ultimately bridge the translational
gap between preclinical studies and
clinical trials our goal is that
improving the accuracy of the
preclinical testing phase will identify
drugs that will fail early before
expensive clinical trials this
improvement will get better drugs to
patients faster at a lower development
cost so our vision at aspect builds on
very rapid advancements in the areas of
cell biology biomaterial science
bio and tissue engineering our highly
interdisciplinary team at aspect has
developed one of the world's most
advanced bio fabrication technologies
that allows us to target key
applications in drug development
cosmetics testing personalized medicine
and regenerative medicine this bio
fabrication technology is based around
3d bioprinting and I'll now discuss this
in more detail so what is 3d printing
it's also called additive manufacturing
and this is where a software design for
a 3d structure it's fabricated one layer
at a time to produce that physical
object substances such as plastics are
heated up and melted and then extruded
from nozzles to fabricate an inanimate
3d structure in a layer-by-layer manner
this is a picture of a common desktop 3d
printer from MakerBot and you can see
that it's produced a plastic model of a
house
so what is bioprinting well in some ways
it's similar to standard 3d printing in
the sense that it also builds a physical
structure based on a digital design but
that's really where the similarity ends
bio printing is difference because
instead of using plastics we print with
a bio ink that contains living cells and
biological scaffolds to fabricate
three-dimensional living structures now
there are multiple approaches to bio
printing each with its own advantages
and disadvantages
inkjet was the first bio printing
technology developed and this was really
adapted from existing two-dimensional
jet technology this is ideal for
printing low viscosity bio inks laser
assisted bio printing is where a donor
ribbon of gold or titanium has bio-ink
suspended underneath it a laser pulse
generates a microbubble at the interface
between the ribbon and the bio ink and
this ejects a small droplet on to a
collection surface extrusion bio
printing is probably the most common
type of bio printing technology in use
today this is where a higher viscosity
bio ink is extruded through a syringe
needle the shear stress is introduced
into the system during that extrusion
sometimes reduces cell viability and
also restricts the speed of printing
stereo lithography is one more type of
bio printing and this is where light
often ultraviolet light is used to
cross-linked liquid bio inks to form a
solid structure an aspect we've
developed a 3d printing technology that
leverages the rapid advancements being
made in micro fluidics
we call this unique approach to bio
printing lab on a printer on the left of
this slide is a schematic of one of our
two material print heads multiple
materials hydrogels are fed into the
printhead and each material channel is
evolved
allowing for flow control these bio inks
could include biomaterials and hydrogels
loaded with cells growth factors
extracellular matrix under the bioactive
compounds right before deep position
a cross-linking fluid is introduced
coaxially and this rapidly cross links
the bio-ink
to generate a solid fiber that is
patterned in 3d on the right hand side
here you can see a cross-section of the
fiber with that cross-linking sheath
fluid surrounding it excess
cross-linking solution is removed by
printing on a porous substrate and
applying a vacuum the lab on a printer
is a new paradigm where we are
integrating complex microfluidic
functions and lab-on-a-chip technology
directly within the printhead itself
this enables real-time material
processing during printing and
on-the-fly control over printed
structure composition in the video on
the left you can see a for material lab
on a printer printhead rapidly switching
between those materials on the right you
can see a time-lapse video of our 3d
bioprinter depositing a hydrogel fiber
about the width of a human hair to
produce a to material three-dimensional
tubular structure
the LLP technology enables precise
control over fiber size on the left is a
close-up image of the focusing
intersection between the biomaterial and
the cross linkers sheath fluid by
changing the pressure ratios of the
sheath fluid in the bio-ink
we can modulate fiber diameter and even
do this on the fly within a printed
structure as shown in the image on the
right where fiber diameter is increasing
moving from left to right fiber
composition is also precisely controlled
because each material channel is valved
we have control of material flow and can
turn material channels on dirt off
allowing us to rapidly switch between
materials we can create individual
material packets with a within a fiber
of a volume of around two-and-a-half
nanoliters this enables the precise P
position of small volumes of precious
cells at the fibre level we can also
introduce different compositional and
structural features at the top you can
see Janus fibers where the fiber itself
is composed of two different parallel
material regions one red and one blue
dye by controlling the pressure ratio
between the material lines we can vary
the proportion of each material within
the fiber on the bottom of the slide we
demonstrate our ability to create core
shell fibers where the core can be a
second material or can be empty to
produce a hollow printed fiber
here we demonstrate a few basic
capabilities of the system to generate
heterogeneous macro structures on the
far left you can see a printed alginate
tubular structure the structure is built
by switching between hydrogel inputs as
the printer switches layers the
structure is reproduced with high
fidelity as the transition between one
material and another does not introduce
start/stop errors that could accumulate
in tall structures with many material
transitions in addition the build time
does not depend on the number of
switching events this approach can be
used to recreate the banded smooth
muscle pattern seen in the human airway
for example in the center we show that
with on-the-fly computer coordination of
on-chip processes within the printer
tool path we can create coaxial
structures with clean boundaries and
demonstrate coordinated intra layer
material switching this structure can be
used to model the various concentric
layers of a tissue like a blood vessel
or the intesting on the right hand side
we demonstrate interweaving one hydrogel
within a solid and thin film of a second
hydrogel this capability can be used as
the basis of a vascularized skin or
tissue patch these structures reproduce
the intended geometry with high fidelity
and they're mechanically robust post
printing so we see an initial
opportunity in developing bioprinted
tissues that could be used at the
preclinical stages of drug development
now I'll briefly go over a few example
3d tissue models for use in preclinical
icings
so the loan is an incredibly complex
branching network of tubes each tube
ends in one of 300 million alveoli per
lung where gas exchange occurs now even
though we can bio-print with fine
control over macro and micro structures
we can't print something as complex as
the human lung yet but we can print some
of the components of the lung in a way
that recreates lifelike function so this
is a fluorescent image of the bands of
smooth muscle cells that wrap around the
airway and it's these muscles that
contract if you have an asthma attack we
decided to model this muscle tissue in
vitro by printing airway muscle cells
into 3d cube Euler structures that have
the ability to contract and we call this
tissue the 3d bio ring so it takes about
30 seconds to print a bio ring tissue
and post printing these bio printed
structures are living and so they have
to be matured and grown in specialized
culture conditions the bio printed
muscle cells are viable and over time
those cells form interconnected
three-dimensional networks and crucially
those printed tissues are able to
contract in a similar way to the real
human airway and so they demonstrate a
biological and disease relevance
function our goal was to use this tissue
to recreate an asthma attack in a dish
now the 3d bearing tackles the lack of
contractile models that mimic airway
biology at present the gold-standard
lab-based
airway contraction model is the
precision-cut lungs light
this is where 200 microns six sections
of living lung tissue are taken and
these tissues have a great advantage in
that they contain all of the relevant
cell types from the biological tissue
however disadvantages of the piece Els
model include limitations of tissue and
donor availability challenging
preparation protocols and a limited
lifespan in culture and all of these
really limit the broad adoption of this
assay aspects 3d bio ring airway is a 3d
bio printed tissue that contains primary
airway smooth muscle cells at
approximately 25 million cells per mil
these cells are viable in 3d culture and
the tissues are functional the bio ring
has a rapid dose-dependent contract our
response to histamine and a similar
relaxation response to the anti asthma
drug salbutamol cells from different
donors can be incorporated matrix
components can be added to manipulate
cellular microenvironment and tissue
production is rapid taking less than a
minute per tissue these tissues are
produced with very high repeatability if
you're interested in learning more than
you can find out on more on our website
where you can access our poster that was
presented in the American Thoracic
Society last year
so to validate buying tissue function we
use the dose response curves for
histamine and salbutamol to calculate
the sensitivity of the tissue to these
compounds the sensitivity is called the
EC 50 or the effective dose that gives
50 percent response and we compared the
EC 50s of the 3d bearings to publish
data for the same compounds in human and
guinea pig precision cut long slices
this comparison table demonstrates that
the bio ring has a physiologically
appropriate contraction response to
histamine and a pharmacologically
appropriate relaxation to salbutamol
suggesting our bioprinted bio ring
tissue is able to generate
physiologically relevant data similar to
the highly complex precision-cut lung
sliced issue assay
so confirming cell viability is always
important when dealing with bioprinted
tissues we've modified and optimized
viability assays specifically for 3d
tissues on the left you can see some
fluorescent images from a Cal scene am
propidium iodide assay this is a
fluorescent stain we're living cells are
shown in green and red cells dead cells
by counting these same cells we can
quantify the percentage of cell
viability in the healthy control image
you can see that the majority of the
cells here are green and almost 100% of
these cells are viable cells if we take
the same tissue and freeze Thorat and
-20 for a few hours to trigger cell
death then you can see that many of the
cells in this sample are red and
therefore dead in the center of the LDH
or lactate dehydrogenase assay this is
an assay where we can measure the
release of lactate dehydrogenase from
dead cells into the surrounding liquid
media the more LDH release the more dead
cells are present this assay can be
measured in a plate based format giving
us higher throughput compared to the
calcium a MPI assay on the right hand
side of the slide you can see data from
an alum are blue or reside urine
reduction assay here living cells reduce
resulting into a fluorescent form that's
released into the surrounding media hi
al Ahmar blue gives Hauser is it is
reflective of high cell viability and a
low signal is representative of low cell
viability as evidenced in the FreeStore
sample again this is suitable for a
plate based assay format so the lactate
dehydrogenase and Alamar blue assays can
be multiplexed to measure dead cells and
healthy cells simultaneously giving a
relative measure of cell viability in
relatively high throughput
so I gave one example of a functional
bioprinted tissue assay with the 3d bio
ring but the lab on a printer technology
is applicable to multiple tissue types
and applications these are two examples
of alternative tissues so in the left
hand side the the 3d liver is a bio
printed liver tissue and we demonstrate
that the hep g2 hepatocyte cell line
printed into 3d structures are viable
and able to grow we tested hypothesize
function using albumin release into the
surrounding media and measured that by
Eliza and we can demonstrate that the
printed tissues really maintain function
for at least 21 days post printing as
seen by extended release of albumin on
the right hand side we have a 3d cancer
model and this is where we can really
probe the interaction between tumor
cells in the surrounding stroma a
potentially vital interaction in the
regulation of tumor immunogenicity and
spreading so we've developed a
multicellular tissue design that
contains a core of tumor cells in this
case HeLa cells ovarian cancer cells
surrounded by healthy stromal cells in
this case dermal fibroblasts and using
this system we're able to investigate
physiological 3-dimensional tumor
stromal interactions in a very
controlled manner in vitro so we've
successfully printed a variety of
adherent primary human cells cell lines
and non-adherent immune cells in this
case cord blood derived mast cells all
of these cells that we tested
demonstrate high cell viability in our
systems and to some extent biologically
appropriate behavior including cell
spreading network formation or colony
formation
now our long-term goal this aspect is to
develop the most complex of tissues for
applications in regenerative medicine
and one application that we're focused
on is knee meniscus tissue for
transplantation the meniscus is a common
site of injury and has poor healing
properties while complete or partial
removal of the meniscus relieves acute
pain it leads to osteoarthritis now
we've partnered with a leading
orthopaedic company on a project to
develop 3d printed meniscus tissue for
implantation that will then graft into
the host tissue and provide a permanent
knee meniscus replacement now recreating
the heterogeneous orientation of fibers
and material composition within the
biological meniscus is essential for
achieving specific mechanical properties
such as tensile and compressive strength
in this video you will see how we're
able to precisely customize fiber
patterning and composition using aspects
proprietary software sweet cue video
you
you
so we're distributing our lab on a
printer technology broadly through the
launch of a commercial bio printing
system called the RX one and we work
with our partners and technology users
to provide a complete tissue fabrication
solution so in addition to the bio
printer platform itself we also supply
print heads bio-ink matrix and tissue
licenses these licenses are detailed
instruction manuals on how to print
culture and assay specific pre validated
tissues such as the 3d bio ring a key
part of our strategy at aspect is to
work closely with our academic partners
to drive forward the development of
impactful tissue applications this
includes access to technology and
know-how as well as supporting grant
applications for example we'll be
working with our initial early platform
access partners on applications ranging
from developing models of uterine muscle
contraction and vascular contraction
that build off our airway contract our
model to printing three-dimensional
neural tissue for studying
neurodegenerative diseases we'd love to
learn more about your applications and
discuss how we could support them
so to summarize aspects lab on a printer
technology is a fundamentally different
approach to bio printing it's a broadly
applicable technology that is able to
reliably and rapidly fabricate living
macro structures with precise control
over micro scale tissue architecture and
also allows control of the cellular
microenvironment at the molecular level
this technology is now available to
research partners and we encourage you
to contact us with any questions or
queries lastly I'd like to acknowledge
all the people that aspect it's only
with a truly world-class
interdisciplinary team that we're able
to execute on achieving a bold vision
and that's exactly what we're building
an aspect I'd also like to acknowledge
all the support
we've received from the different
funding agencies and I'd like to thank
you for your attention thanks very much
thank you dr. Ward's words for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower lap
of the presentation window type of
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click on the send button
well answer is many requests with real
time for let's get started our first
question is what are the advantages of
3d bioprinting versus feeding cells onto
scaffolds those seeding cells on
scaffolds has certain limitations and
they are reproducibility or lack of
reproducibility between samples doing
cell seeding in a manual way it's
challenging to recreate every tissue in
the same way with bio printing we're
able to reproduce and create a tissue
that's been designed in software and so
that tissue is produced in a very
consistent and reliable way it's also
produced in an automated way
so you know we can produce many tissues
in sequence or even in parallel
sometimes to increase efficiency of that
tissue production
what are some advantages of the LLP bio
printing technology vs. other bio
printing methods so I mean I discussed
some of the various approaches to bio
printing and each approach really has
its own advantages and disadvantages
with the lab on a printer approach what
we've been able to do is really leverage
micro fluidics
to use a coaxial flow focusing
technology and so what this allows us to
do is generate a cell loaded hydrogel
fiber on chip but protect those cells
from the shear forces that they would
otherwise be exposed to in other types
of bio printing technologies so really
we believe that because there is very
little shear stress in our system we're
able to produce tissues with cells that
are at a very high viability and also
print at high speeds so we think we have
a very rapid tissue fabrication
technology as well you mentioned
customization of bio x how does this
work
so the the by links that we print can be
loaded with a variety of different
growth factors matrix factors really any
soluble bioactive compound and we supply
kind of basic bio inks to our to our
users and that's a broadly applicable
bio ink that's been validated with a
variety of different cell types but
sometimes there's a cell type that needs
a very sort of specific micro
environment in order to grow or
differentiate in the right way and so
what we're able to do is really
customize those bio inks by adding
specific components to to those inks to
really trigger the the correct cell
growth and differentiation of those
cells
has a tissue license work the tissue
license can be thought of as a detailed
instruction manual on how to how to
print a tissue so that includes
information on things like cell density
and cell type preparing cells and then
also printing parameters such as the
pressure settings on chip and then
moving through that kind of tissue
process we also supply information on
how to culture those tissues in the
appropriate manner and then also how to
say them so for example with the 3d
bearing tissue we provide detailed
information on how to perform the
contraction assays and even how to
quantify the data that comes out of
those assays so it's a sort of an
end-to-end tissue instruction manual how
do you validate the tissues you print
are functional the tissue validation
really depends on the type of tissue
that we're dealing with so for the the
contractile bio ring airway tissue what
we did what we did there was we tested
contraction in response to a variety of
compounds that were known previously to
cause contraction in human Airways so
histamine for example is well known to
cause airway contraction and so we used
that compound to test the contractile
response in our bio rings and did that
of various concentrations to calculate
the sensitivity of those rings and then
really compare that sensitivity to
pre-existing data that comes from their
other tissue models or even clinical
data and really it if you know as we
develop other tissues then they're
validated in very similar ways so it's
really using a panel of compounds with
known effect known clinical effects and
known preclinical effects
and then testing those in our system to
confirm that our tissues basically
reproduce those those known effects for
those compounds okay we have time for
one more question can you buy a print
samples using the LLP and yeah we
printed a variety of different cells
including primary human cells some of
those are kind of tricky to grow and
culture so we've definitely printed some
you know relatively fragile cell types
using this system and some of our
collaborators and our technology users
do have stem cell based projects that
they're focused on so for example one of
our users is is using induced
pluripotent stem cells and printing
those to derive neuronal tissues for
testing and researching
neurodegenerative diseases and testing
potential therapeutics for those
diseases so yeah we we're certainly
working with people who are interested
and using our system for for printing
stem cells I would like to once again
thank dr. Samuel watts for his first
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go
I want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through August 24 2017 you'll
receive an email from Lavery's letting
me know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon goodbye
thank you